YOU ON 8 NEWS NOW AT 04:00PM
US GO BACK TO LAS VEGAS. NOW.
>> THANK YOU GERRI TODAY IS
NATIONAL MEN'S GROOMING DAY
AND FELL AS WE HAVE A GREAT
SPOT FOR YOU TO GET YOUR LOOK
DIALED IN HERE TELL US MORE
IT'S NICK AND MIKEY AND THEY
ARE FROM THE BARBERSHOP CUTS
COCKTAILS WHICH IS INSIDE THE
COSMOPOLITAN WELCOME GUYS
DOING HAS GOT A GREAT BEFORE
WE GOING WITH THE STYLE TELL
ME MORE ABOUT THE SO YOU U U U
THE BARBERSHOP WE ARE FULL
SERVICE SHOP WE DO OFFER
ANYTHING FROM YOU  KNOW I
BROUGHT TRANSIT YOUR WAX SANTA
BEARD TRIMS SHAYS HOTEL HAIR
CUTS AND ALL THE IN-BETWEEN
PRETTY DO IT ALL AND IT'S FOR
NATIONAL GROOMING DAY WE WANT
TO GET A LITTLE BEER
DEMONSTRATION TODAY IS I THINK
WE'RE GOING TO FOCUS REALLY
KIND OF SHOWING THE TRANSITION
OF THE FACE OVER THE BY
BRINGING IN TIGHTER AND THE
SIZE THE 4 IN THE FRONT AND
THEN STARTING WITH YOUR POINT
HERE BRINGING IT UP TO THE JOB
LINED UP HERE.
>> WHILE ALSO GIVING THE
VOLUME OF TOP ALLOWS YOU TO
HAVE MORE OF A LONGER LOOK
VERSUS A WIDER LOCATED ISN'T
WRITTEN RIGHT NOW IS SOMETHING
TO DO WITH THAT WITH WITH LIKE
MIKEY COMES IN GUYS BOTH
BARBERS THERE YOERU ERDO ERERGE
EVALUATION TO SATOY HEY SHUY
THIS KIND KIOF CUT.
>> AND ATHIS KIND OF FLOW INTO
BEER.
>>
SO
YES
WE START OUT BY
LOOKING AT YOUR CIVI L BO WL  A
THEN WEEN MOVE RIGHE T TO
>> ABOUT BO
>> IS A TRICK IS TO THE VERY
WE KEEP  IT SHORT ARE DOWN
BELOW NOLORTH THAT WTHILL TTHUS
THDOTHWN TTHHERETH EXTHACTLTHY
TO STICK TO THE  RIGHT BELOW
NECK JAW LINE NENERIGHT HERE.
>> AND THEN BRING IT UP AS
YOU'RE DOING THIS MIKE I LOVE
THE TEXTURE I LOVE I LOVE THE
TEXTURE OF YOUR HAIR IS THIS
THE STYLE ACTUALLY KIND OF
COMING FORWARD AS AN ECONOMIC
SAID IS THIS TO LOOK FOR THE
BALL.
>> I THINK THE REMOTE IS
REALLY ENTERING NOW
>> I'M JUST KIND OF IN BETWEEN
CARS RIGHT I SAVE MY HEAD
BECAUSE I DID I DIDN'T.
>> NOT JUST TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT NEXT LOVE SO WE'VE BEEN
DOING THIS FOR FUN, WHAT AS
FAR AS CALLING TO AN CALL ON
THE TOP HERE WAS THE COLOR FOR
GUYS THIS FALL.
>> WHAT COLOR THAT'S IN MY
HAIR HAWAS JUST AN ACCIDENT SIT
AND IT IT WAS A LONG I PUT IN
MY EARBUDS GOT TO GO WITH LIKE
THE PINK IS COLORS EVEN SOME
OF THE MORE ACTION CLOSE PINK
PURPLE GRAY'S STUFF LIKE THAT
AND SO SEEING A LOT OF YOU
GUYS DO GREAT CUTS THERE YOU
GET A COMPLIMENTARY DRINK WHEN
YOU'RE GETTING A THERE WAS
ALSO THE SPEAK EASY TO AND ARE
GETTING A A LOOK STYLE DAMAGES
OF GREAT ARE SPEAKEASY WHERE
OPEN 7 DAYS A SUNDAY TO
TUESDAY WERE OPEN AT 08:00PM
AND THE REST OF THE WEEK WELL
UP ARE W AE OP AEN  A A A A A A
>> AND WE'VE HAD LAST WEEK WE
CAME CABY IT WAS
TALK ACRO SS THE COUNTRY. YEAH,
I MEAN YOU GUYS ARE THE HOT
SPOT WHEN IT COMES TO STYLES
AND ALSO FOR PERFORMANCES.
WELL YES, AND THEN WE HAVE ON
TUESDAY NIGHT WE HAVE ROCKS
ARE KARAOKE KARAOKE NIGHT BUT
INSTEAD OF LIKE A MACHINE AND
A DJ ARE HOUSE BEHIND YOU AND
THEN WE WILD WEST WEDNESDAY AS
AS A THANK COUNTRY ROCK NIGHT.
BUT OUR HOUSE BAND THEY'RE ALL
LIKE YOU KNYOOW MUSICIANS THAT
WERE SUCCESSFUL IN THEIR OWN
YEAH, THERE'S THE ALL THE GUYS
THEY WERE ALL IN MY 1000 YEAH
AND SO THEY HAVE FRIENDS THAT
COME SO WE'VE HAD A MACHINE
GUN KELLY CAME BY AND
PERFORMED YEAR ON WE HAD MACY
GRAY, BUT A LOT OF REAL COOL
KINGS OF LEON AND ZAC BROWN
BAND CAME AFTER THE CMA IS AND
THAT ACTUALLY SIGNED THE LIST
THAT JUST GET ON THAT FOR THE
KARAOKE IT'S HUGE REGULARS I
GOT TO WRAP A REAL CUT WHAT'S
THE HAIRSTYLE FOR GUYS THIS
FALL.
>> WHAT'S THE LOOK A LOT OF
PEOPLE ARE GOING THE MOMENT
LOOK AT SOME OF THEM ALL A LOT
OF TEXTURE OF TOP TIER ARE
EXECUTIVE PRODUCERS I HAVE A
MOMENT NOW NOW